the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon video all right my friends
in this new video i will be going over a
lot more information that will help you
understand exactly what we will see
happen in hbo's new game of thrones
series house of the dragon now for those
of you who don't know i have already
made one video where i went over all of
the details that lead up to the dance of
the dragons in that first video i
basically set the stage for what
happened immediately after king viserys
died and allison and rhaenyra formed
their respective sides known as the
blacks and the greens what you will see
and hear in this new video today is so
much more interesting than that if you
ask me this is when the dance of the
dragons officially begins this is when
we will actually start to see some blood
get shed
now if you have been watching a lot of
my videos then you should already have a
good idea about what we will see at the
beginning of house of the dragon during
its first season basically what this
show will be about is what happens after
king viserys dies when everyone starts
fighting for the iron throne now like
i've said in other videos before king
viserys dies he makes his daughter
rhaenyra targaryen his heir for the iron
throne because he could not initially
have any sons of his own a lot of the
high lords of westeros even came to
king's landing to swear fealty to
rhaenyra because viceros was setting her
up to take over after he was gone
however before he dies he eventually
does get married again to a woman named
alison hightower who also just so
happens to be the daughter of his hand
of the king serato hightower once he
marries alison hightower it's not long
before they start having sons but even
after that happens viserys still keeps
rhaenara as his heir for the iron throne
he doesn't make any adjustments to his
line of succession once he dies however
rhaenyra isn't there to immediately take
over as the new queen of westeros
unfortunately for her she is living on
dragonstone when this happens and she
doesn't find out her father has even
died until many many days later when she
eventually does find out her father king
viserys is dead queen alicent as well as
her newly formed green council already
have king's landing on lockdown not only
that but queen alicent already has her
son aegon sitting on the iron throne
with the crown on his head when rhaenyra
and daemon finally receive this
information on dragonstone they form a
council of their own known as the black
council and they immediately start
moving forward in an effort to take back
what's rightfully queen rhaenyra
targaryens now let me show you what
happens next just like i did in the
first video i will go over all of the
information george rr martin has written
in fire and blood because this is
exactly what hbo is adapting into house
of the dragon we will see all of this
happen in the new show and i must say
this is when things get very interesting
now let's begin
the name of this chapter is a sun for a
sun
aegon had been named the new king in the
dragonpit of king's landing while
rhaenyra was queen on dragonstone every
effort at reconciliation having failed
the dance of the dragons now began in
earnest on driftmark the sea snake lore
coreless velaryon ships set sail from
hall and spice down to close the gaulet
this would stop all the trade to and
from king's landing soon after daemon
targaryen flew his dragon karaxis to the
trident rhaenyra's sons left as well
jakari's valerion was flying north on
his dragon vermax while his brother
lucario's flew south on his dragon or
rax now the first thing we will see is
what happened at harrenhal we did see a
glimpse of this location in the new
teaser trailer released by hbo although
most of it was in ruins the castle's
giant curtain wall still made it
incredibly formidable however as we all
know aegon the dragon had already shown
us that this great castle is vulnerable
from the sky one look at harrenhal and
you can still see what balarion the
black dread had done to it now with its
lord larry strong away in king's landing
harrenhal was but lightly garrisoned
there were not very many men here when
daemon arrived on the back of his dragon
now having no wish to suffer the same
fate of black heron its elderly
castellan sir simon strong was quick to
strike his banners when caraxes lighted
atop the tower in addition to the castle
daemon targaryen captured the not
inconsiderable wealth of how strong and
a dozen valuable hostages among them sir
simon and his grandsons the castle small
folk became his captives as well the
sudden bloodless fall of black heron's
seat was counted a great victory for
queen rhaenyra and her blacks it served
as a sharp reminder of the skill of
daemon targaryen and the power of his
dragon karaxis and it gave rhaenara a
stronghold right in the heart of
westeros to which her allies could rally
and rhaenyra had many such in the lands
watered by the trident when daemon sent
forth his call to arms they rose up all
along the rivers knights and men at arms
and humble small folk who yet remembered
rhaenyra targaryen the realms delight so
beloved of her father hundreds and then
thousands buckled on their sword belts
and donned their mail or grabbed a hoe
in a crude wooden shield and began to
make their way to harrenhal to fight for
king viserys's little girl the lords of
the trident having more to lose did not
move as fast but soon enough they too
began to throw their lots in with the
new queen the grizzled lord of pink
maiden spoke for many when he said i
swore her my sword i'm older now but not
so old that i've forgotten the words i
said and it happens i still have the
sword now this was actually another
scene that we have already seen a
glimpse of in the new teaser trailer we
saw a lot of the high lord swearing
fealty to not only king viserys
targaryen but his daughter rhaenyra
targaryen as well meanwhile a very
different story was unfolding out to the
east where jacary's velaryon descended
upon the eerie of his young dragon
vermax to win the veil of aaron for his
mother rhaenyra the maiden of the vale
lady jane aaron was 5 and 30 20 years
older than jacary's neverwed lady jane
had reigned over the veil since the
death of her father and elder brothers
at the hands of the stone crows of the
hills when she was three mushroom tells
us that this famous maiden was in truth
a highborne harlot with a ferocious
appetite for men and gives us a
salacious tale of how she offered
jacarys the allegiance of the veil if
only he could bring her to climax with
his tongue in this instance we must be
grateful for grand maester monken's
account for he alone confines himself to
the high hall of the erie rather than
its bed chambers your prince daemon
targaryen used his first wife most
cruelly it is true but not withstanding
your mother's bad taste in consorts she
remains a rightful queen and mine own
blood besides and aaron on her mother's
side in this world of men we women must
band together the veil and its knights
shall stand with her if her grace will
grant me one request when jacarys asked
what that might be she answered dragons
i have no fear of armies many and more
have broken themselves against my bloody
gate and the eerie is known to be
impregnable however you have descended
on us from the sky as queen vicinia once
did during aegon's conquest and there
was nothing i could do to stop you send
me dragon riders and so he agreed and
lady jane knelt before him and bait her
warriors to kneel and all swore him
their swords then on jakery's sword
north across the fingers and the waters
of the bite he lighted briefly at
sisterton where lord burrell and lord
sunderland showed him respect by
agreeing to give him the backing of the
three sisters he then flew onto white
harbor where lord desmond manderly met
with him in his merman's court here is
where jacarys faced a much shrewder
bargainer white harbor is not
unsympathetic to your mother's dilemma
manderly declared my own forebearers
were disboiled of their birthright when
our enemies drove us into exile on these
cold northern shores when the old king
visited us long ago he spoke of the
wrong that had been done to us and swore
that he would make things right his
grace offered the hand of his daughter
to my great grandsire that our two
houses might be made as one but the girl
died and his words were forgotten now
jacarys knew what was being asked of him
before he left white harbor a compact
was drawn up and signed by the term of
which lord manderly's youngest daughter
would be wed to his brother joffrey once
the war was over
finally vermax carried jacarys to
winterfell to treat with its formidable
young lord kregan stark the snows lay
deep upon the ground and a cold wind was
howling from the north and lord stark
was in the midst of his preparations for
the coming winter yet he gave jacarys a
warm welcome snow and ice and cold made
vermax ill-tempered at his set so
jacarius did not linger long amongst the
northmen but many different tales came
out of his short visit grand maester
monken's accounts say that creighton and
jacarys took a liking to each other for
the boy reminded the lord of winterfell
of his own younger brother who had died
many years ago it is said that they
drank together hunted together trained
together and swore an oath of
brotherhood sealed in blood
we also saw something like this in the
new teaser trailer when we saw two
characters shaking hands that were
covered in blood now this seems more
credible than september stacey's version
of these events wherein jacary spends
most of his visit attempting to convince
lord kregan to give up his false gods
and accept the worship of the seven but
we look to mushroom to find the story
other chronicles emit nor does he fail
us now
his account introduces a young maiden or
wolf girl as he dubs her with the name
of sarah snow so smitten was jacare's
with this creature a bastard daughter of
the late lord rickon stark that he lay
with her overnight on learning that his
guest had claimed the maidenhood of his
bastard sister lord kregen became most
roth and only softened when sarah snow
said that jacarys had taken her for his
wife they had spoken their vows in
winterfell's own godswood before a heart
tree and only then had she given herself
to him wrapped in furs amidst the snows
as the old gods looked on jakari's
velaryon had been betrothed to his
cousin bayla since he was four and she
was two and from all known of his
character it seemed most unlikely that
he would break such a solemn agreement
to guard the uncertain virtue of some
half-wild unwashed northern bastard if
indeed there ever lived to sarah snow
and if indeed the prince of dragonstone
did decide to dally with her that is no
more than other princes have done before
and will do again on the morrow but the
talk of marriage is ridiculous now
mushroom also claims that vermax left
dragon eggs at winterfell which is also
absurd while it is true that determining
the sex of a living dragon is an eye or
an impossible task no other source
mentions vermax laying as much as a
single egg so it must be assumed that he
was a male dragon
septon bars speculation that the dragons
can switch their sex when they need to
is ludicrous to even consider this we do
know cregan stark and jacarys reached an
accord and signed and sealed the
agreement that grain maester monken
names the pact of ice and fire like many
such agreements it was to be sealed with
a marriage lord kriegen's son rickon was
a year old jacares was as yet unmarried
and childless but it was assumed that he
would sire children of his own once his
mother set the iron throne under this
new agreement jakari's firstborn
daughter would be sent north at the age
of seven to be fostered at winterfell
until such time as she was old enough to
marry lord kriegen's heir when the
prince of dragonstone took his dragon
back into the cold autumn sky he did so
with the knowledge that he had won three
great lords and all their bannermen for
his mother
though his 15th name day was still half
a year away jacarys had shown himself to
be a man in a worthy heir to the iron
throne now had his brother's shorter
safer flight gone as well much bloodshed
and grief might well have been averted
the tragedy that befell lucari's
velaryon at storm's end was never
planned on this all of our sources agree
the first battles in the dance of the
dragons were fought with letters and
ravens with threats decrees and
blandishments the murder of lord
beesberry at the green council was not
yet widely known most believe that his
lordship to be languishing in some
dungeon while sundry familiar faces were
no longer seen about court no heads had
emerged above the castle gates and many
still hoped that the matter of
succession might be resolved easily the
stranger had something else in mind
however for surely it was his dread hand
behind the ill chance that brought the
two princelings together at storm's end
when the dragon arrax raced before a
gathering storm to deliver lucario's
velaryon to the safety of the castle
yard only to then find aemon targaryen
there before him boros baratheon was a
man of much different character than his
father aemon targaryen had been
uncertain what sort of welcome he would
receive when he set out but storms then
welcomed him with feasts and hunts and
jousting lord boris was more than
willing to entertain his suit i have
four daughters he told aemon targaryen
choose any that you like cass is the
oldest she'll be the first one to flower
but flores is much better looking and if
it's a clever wife you want there's my
daughter maris rhaenara had taken house
baratheon for granted for far too long
his lordship told aemond he had nothing
against women lord boros went on to say
he loved his girls very much but a son
should the gods ever grant him a son of
his own blood storm's end would go to
him not to his sisters
why should the iron throne be any
different and with the royal marriage
and the offering rhaenara's cause was
lost she would see that when she learned
that she had lost storm zen he would
tell her so himself we have no record of
which daughter aemon targaryen finally
decided on the mushroom tells us he
kissed all four to taste the nectar of
their lips save that it was not maris
grand maester monken writes that aemond
and lord barris were haggling over dates
and dowries on the morning lucario's
velaryon arrived aemon's dragon veigar
sensed his coming first guardsmen
walking the battlements of the castle's
mighty walls held their weapons in fear
when she woke with a roar that shook the
very foundations of durhan's defiance
even lucari's dragon iraq showed fear
before that sound we are told mushroom
would have us believe that the lightning
was flashing to the east and a heavy
rain falling as lucario's leapt off his
dragon his mother's message held firmly
in his hand he must surely have known
what he was walking into just by veigar
already being there so would it have
come as no shock when aemon targaryen
confronted him in the round hall among
those who witnessed the meeting was sir
byron swann second son of lord of
stonehelm in the dornish marshes who
would have his own role to play later in
the dance of the dragons so during this
occasion we don't only have to rely on
the accounts of grand maester monken
mushroom and septinus stace none of them
were at storm's end when this happened
but many others were so we have no
shortage of first-hand accounts look at
this sad creature my lord aemon
targaryen called out little luke strong
the bastard to luke he said you are wet
bastard is it raining or did you piss
yourself in fear luceri's valerion
addressed himself only to lord baratheon
lord boros i have brought you a message
from my mother the queen
the horror of dragonstone he means aemon
targaryen strode forward and made to
snatch the letter from lucari's hand but
lord boris roared a command and his
knights intervened separating the boys
from each other one of them brought
rhaenyra's letter to the deus where his
lordship set upon the throne of the
storm kings of old no man can truly know
what boris baratheon was feeling at that
moment some say his lordship was
red-faced and abashed as a man might be
if his lawful wife found him a bed with
another woman others declared that boris
looked to be relishing the moment for it
made him feel good that both the king
and the queen were seeking his support
mushroom who was not there says that he
was drunk
septinus stace who wasn't there says he
was fearful yet all the witnesses agree
on what lord boros said and did
never a man of letters he handed the
queen's letter to his maester who
cracked the seal and whispered the
message into his lordship's ear a frown
stole across lord boris's face he
stroked his beard scout at lucari's
velaryon and said and if i do as your
mother bids which one of my daughters
will you marry boy he gestured at the
four girls lucario's could only blush my
lord i am not free to marry he said i am
betrothed to my cousin reina i thought
as much lord boros said
go home and tell the [ __ ] your mother
that the lord of storm's end is not a
dog that she can whistle up at the need
to set against her foes and lucario's
then knew that it was time for him to go
but aemon targaryen drew his sword and
said hold strong first you must give me
what you owe
then he ripped off the cover from his
eye and flung it to the floor to show
the sapphire beneath sitting in his eye
socket you have a knife just as you did
then take out your eye and i will let
you leave
now for those of you who don't know
lucaries and amon had fought before and
as you can see by what he just said
lucario's had slashed his dagger at
aemon's face removing his eye this is
actually why we see allison running at
rhaenyra in the teaser trailer she was
so angry after what lou carey's had done
to her son she rushed at rhaenyra
demanding that lucario's lose an eye as
well this was over aemon saying lucaries
was a bastard suggesting that he was
fathered by a strong and not a valerion
now back at storm's end lucario's
remembered what his mom said he told
aemond i will not fight you i came here
as an envoy not a knight you came here
as a craven and a traitor aemon
targaryen answered i will have your eye
or your life strong at that lord boris
grew uneasy not here he grumbled he came
as an envoy i want no blood shed under
my roof
so his guard separated them and escorted
lucario's valerion from the round hall
back to the castle yard where his dragon
iraq's was hunched down in the rain
awaiting his return and there it might
have ended if not for the lord's
daughter maris she was still angry that
aemon wanted one of his sisters instead
of her was it one of your eyes he took
or one of your balls maris asked him in
a voice sweet as honey i'm so glad you
chose my sister because i want a husband
that still has his balls amon
targaryen's mouth twisted in a rage and
he turned once more to lord boros asking
him for his leave the lord of storm's
end shrugged and answered it is not for
me to tell you what to do when you are
not beneath my roof and his knights
moved aside as amon ran outside the
storm was still raging thunder rolled
across the castle the rain fell in
blinding sheets and great bolts of blue
white lightning lit the world as bright
as day it was bad weather for flying
even for a dragon and iraq's was
struggling to stay aloft when prince
aemon mounted veigar and went after him
had the sky been calm lucario's might
have been able to outfly aemon fur
iraq's was younger and swifter but the
day was as black as amon targaryen's
heart and so the dragons met above
shipbreaker bay watchers on the castle
wall saw distant blasts of flame and
heard a shriek cut right through the
thunder then the dragons were locked
together in the sky
lightning crackling around them veigar
was five times the size of her foe the
hardened survivor of a hundred battles
if there was a fight it could not have
lasted long iraq's fell broken to be
swallowed by the storm-lashed waters of
the bay
his head and neck washed up beneath the
cliffs below storm's end three days
later to make a feast for crabs and
seagulls mushroom says that lucario's
lifeless body washed up as well and it's
also said that aemon removed his eyes
and gave them to lady maris on a bed of
seaweed but that seems excessive some
say vegar snatched lucari's off his
dragon's back and swallowed him whole it
has even been said that lucari survived
the fall swam to safety but lost all
memory of who he was spending the rest
of his days as a simple-minded fisherman
lucari's valerion died with his dragon
monken and sis he was 13 years of age
his body was never found and with his
death the war of ravens and envoys and
marriage alliances came to an end in the
war of fire and blood officially began
aemon targaryen who would henceforth be
known as aemon the kinslayer to his foes
arrived back in king's landing having
won the alliance of storm's end for his
brother aegon and the undying hostility
of queen rhaenyra if he thought to
receive a hero's welcome he was sadly
mistaken
his mother queen alice sense flesh went
milk white when she heard what he had
done crying mother had mercy on us all
nor was serato hightower happy with this
news either you only lost one eye he has
reported to have said how could you be
so blind the king himself did not share
their concerns however aegon ii of his
name welcomed his brother aemon
targaryen home with a great feast hailed
him as the true blood of the dragon and
announced that he had made a good
beginning on dragonstone queen rhaenyra
collapsed when total luke's death luke's
younger brother joffrey swore a terrible
oath of vengeance against aemond and
lord boros only the intervention of the
sea snake and his wife rhaenys kept the
boy from mounting his own dragon at once
as the black council set to consider how
to strike back a raven arrived from
harrenhal an eye for an eye a son for a
son daemon targaryen wrote lucery shall
be avenged let it not be forgotten in
his youth daemon targaryen had been the
prince of the city his face and laughed
familiar to every thief [ __ ] and
gambler and flea bottom daemon still had
many friends in king's landing as well
as followers amongst the gold cloaks we
also saw this in the teaser trailer in
several different scenes we saw daemon
targaryen accompanied by members of the
city watch like i've said before he was
once their commander and even after he
left king's landing some of them still
followed him fiercely now unbeknownst to
king aegon the han serado or the queen
he had allies at court as well even on
their green council and one other
go-between a special friend he trusted
utterly who knew the wine sinks and rats
that festered in the shadows of the red
keep as well as daemon himself once had
and moved easily through the shadows of
the city he reached out to this stranger
by secret ways to set a terrible
vengeance into motion amidst the stews
of flea bottom daemon's go between found
suitable instruments
one of them had been a sergeant in the
city watch big and brutal he had lost
his golden cloak for beating a horde of
death while in a drunken rage the other
was a rat catcher in the red keep their
real names are lost to history they are
remembered now only by the names of
blood and cheese it said that cheese
knew the red keep better than the shape
of his own [ __ ] mushroom tells us the
hidden doors and secret rooms that
maegor the cruel had built were as
familiar to the red catcher as the rats
he hunted using a forgotten passageway
cheese led blood into the heart of the
castle unseen by any guard now some say
their target was the king himself but
aegon was accompanied by the king's
guard wherever he went and even cheese
knew of no way in and out of maegor sold
fast save over the drawbridge that
spanned the dry moat and its formidable
iron spikes now the tower of the hand
was less secure the men crept up through
the walls avoiding the spearmen standing
guard at the doors serato's rooms were
of no interest to them instead they
slipped into his daughter's chambers one
floor below alison had taken up
residence there after the death of king
viserys when her son aegon moved into
maegor's holdfast with his own queen
once inside cheese bound and gagged
alison while blood strangled her bed
maid then they settled down to wait for
they knew it was the custom of aegon's
wife and sister queen helena to bring
her children to see their grandmother
every evening before bed blind to her
danger helena arrived as dusk settled
over the castle joined by her three
children jaehaerys and jahara were six
male or only two as they walked into the
chambers helena was holding his little
hand and calling out her mother's name
blood barred the door and slain the
queen's guardsmen while cheese emerged
and snatched up melor screaming you all
died blood told her grace helena kept
her calm and it said who are you she
demanded of the men
debt collector said cheese an eye for an
eye a son for a son we only want one to
square things away which one you want to
lose your grace once she realized what
he meant queen helena begged the men to
kill her instead a wife's not a son said
blood it has to be a boy
she's warned the queen that she need to
decide soon before blood grew bored and
raped her little girl
decide he said or we kill them all on
her knees weeping helena named her
youngest melor mayhap she thought the
boy was too young to understand or may
happens it was because the older boy
jaehaerys was king aegon's firstborn son
in heir next in line for the iron throne
you hear that little boy cheese
whispered to melor your mama once you
dead then he gave blood a grin and the
hulking swordsman slew jaehaerys instead
striking off the boy's head with a
single blow helena began to scream
strange to say the rat catcher and the
butcher were true to their word they did
no further harm to queen elena or her
surviving children but rather fled with
little jaehaerys head in hand a hue and
a cry went up but cheese knew the secret
passageways as the guards did not and
the killers made their escape several
days later blood was seized at the gate
of the gods trying to leave king's
landing with the head of prince
jaehaerys hidden in one of his saddle
sacks under torture he confessed that he
had been taken into harrenhal to collect
his reward from daemon targaryen he also
gave up a description of the horror he
claimed hired them an older woman
foreign by her voice and cloaked and
hooded the other harlots called her
misery now misery is also known as
masaria mistress of daemon targaryen we
saw her in the new teaser trailer as
well standing right behind daemon on
dragonstone
now after 13 days of a brutal beating
blood was at last allowed to die queen
alison had commanded laris clubfoot to
learn his real name so that she might
bathe in the blood of his wife and
children but our sources do not say if
this actually happened sir luther
largent and his city watch searched the
street of silk from top to bottom but no
trace of cheese or the white worm lady
misery was ever found in his grief and
fury king aegon commanded that all of
the city's rat catchers be taken out and
hanged and this was done
serato hightower brought 100 cats into
the red key to take their spot though
blood and cheese had spared her life
queen helena cannot be said to have
survived that fateful dusk afterwards
she would not eat nor bathe nor leave
her chambers and she could no longer
stand to look upon her song maylor
knowing that she had named him to die
the king had no recourse but to take the
boy from her and give him over to their
mother queen alicent to raise as if he
were her own aegon and his wife slept
separately thereafter and queen helena
sank deeper and deeper into madness
while the king raged and drank and raged
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you